bon pas étonnant que votre livre soit
numéro un des ventes parce que vous êtes
un type génial
voilà alors vous êtes éthologue alors
l'éthologie c'est l'observation de
l'être humain dans son milieu naturel ça
d'abord été fait pour des animaux puis
vous l'avez appliqué à l'être humain
vous êtes donc éthologue psychanalyste
et inventeur du concept de résilience
alors le mot vient de la physique je
peux être trop compliqué mais quand même
peut le savoir
la résilience en physique c'est
l'aptitude des matériaux à résister aux
fortes pressions et donc pour les êtres
humains c'est le travail que vous avez
fait c'est à cliquer la psychologie et
donc c'est la capacité des êtres humains
à surmonter les pires traumatisme à
redevenir vivant après un traumatisme
profond et je dirais à utiliser cette
blessure c'est à dire un peu comme au
judo canton quand on se sert de la force
de l'autre pour le faire tomber
voilà c'est ça alors le premier
résilient c'est vous on pourrait dire
car vous êtes évidemment comme j'ai dit
l'inventeur du concept mais surtout vous
avez été victime étant enfant d'un grave
traumatisme vos parents juifs d'origine
russe ont été arrêtés à bordeaux à
l'époque de maurice papon votre mère en
40 de votre père en 43 votre père était
arrêtée sur son lit d'hôpital et vous
avez été éloignés de bordeaux dans une
pension
et puis quand plus personne ne pouvait
payer la pension évidemment vous avez
été mis à l'assistance publique vous
aviez à l'époque quatre ans hélas une
institutrice dénommé marguerite vous a
caché pendant un an et demi jusqu'à ce
que vous soyez dénoncé par un
instituteur voilà en suisse est enfermé
à la synagogue de bordeaux qui était à
l'époque transformé en prison et vous
parvenez à vous évader grâce c'est
extraordinaire cette histoire grâce à
une infirmière de la croix rouge
or vous ne parlez jamais de cette
histoire vous même à votre analystes
vous n'en parlez pas et puis un jour
vous avez voulu remettre la médaille des
justes à cette marguerite et là il y
avait la presse il y avait l'express il
avait été afin et serra et voudrait
obliger de
d'avouer sa est-ce que donc c'est un
brésilien
voilà le premier résident je dirais
est-ce que vous avez rebondi est-ce que
vous n'aviez pas parler à votre analyse
parce que vous ne pouviez pas en parler
ou vous ne vouliez pas en parler c'est
bien vous me racontiez ma vie comme ça
je lui ai appris des tas de choses des
erreurs non non j'avais six ans j'ai été
arrêté quand j'ai été condamné à mort
j'avais 6 ans j'en ai parlé à mon
analyste
mais lui n'en a pas parlé en publie la
carte de l'année voilà lorsque j'ai pas
dit c'est que l'instituteur qui vous a
dénoncé quand vous étiez chez marguerite
vous l'avez revue un jour vous avez mais
je n'ai revu quand il faisait le tri de
ce qui allait mourir et de ceux qui on
faisait croire qu'ils allaient
travailler
ouais et gelé reconnu alors sur papon au
moment où le procès le nom de votre
famille était souvent le site est
d'ailleurs pendant pendant le procès
vous dites si on condamne papon à ce
moment là il faut mettre six mois au
chef de bureau
deux mois à la secrétaire est en fait
ford et condamné la france entière donc
que vous n'étiez pas très favorables
finalement au fait qu'on choisisse papon
en particulier non j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on cherche à comprendre ce qui s'est
passé mais je pense que la france
entière n'aurait pas été condamné je
pense que très peu de gens se sont
engagés dans la résistance on les
connaît ils sont nommés très peu de gens
se sont engagés dans la collaboration on
les connaît aussi et je pense qu'il n'y
a aucune raison les prisonniers du passé
je pense que l'histoire sert à déclarer
la guerre et que au contraire rien ne
nous oblige à nous y soumettre on peut
très bien inventer de nouvelles manières
de vivre ensemble alors et publié déjà
deux livres sur la résilience
aujourd'hui par elle
le troisième qui s'appelle le murmure
des fantômes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
alors fantôme parce que on est mort en
fait c'est ça on a été mauvais on et
revenant 1
et vous savez comment les normaux se
comporte avec les revenants 1 ils sont
initiés ils ont côtoyé la mort ils en
ont triomphé ils sont le celle où ils
ont peut-être baptisé avec la mort dont
qui sont initiés ils ont un savoir que
les gens anormalement normaux non pas
parce que pour être normal il faut être
amputé d'une partie de ses potentiels
donc on devient anormalement normal
c'est pas normal d'être normal les
normaux pas tous les appeler les ormeaux
patinoire se rend sur andy quelque chose
encore plus drôle
ils disent il est à moi j'aime beaucoup
parce qu'il est odieux et il dit on ne
devient pas normal impunément
voilà fantôme parce que ce sont des
revenants et murmure parce qu'on les
écoute pas d'où le murmure des fantômes
voilà alors vous raconter un certain
nombre de cas évidemment celui qui est
le plus éblouissant parce qu'on la
connaît tous c'est marilyn monroe
évidemment kiki qui était qui étaient
quittes est belle certes mais qui était
morte psychiquement par manque d'amour
pendant son enfance
voilà l a jamais été vivante on a été
piégé par son apparence parce que
tellement elle était belle et
chaleureuse on a cru qu'elle était
vivante mais en fait elle a jamais été
vivante elle a toujours était morte et
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être mort pour
ne pas vivre et n a jamais vraiment vécu
cette personne n'a compris parce qu'elle
restait dans son lit pendant des
semaines entières sans boire sans se
laver sans manger et personne ne s'en
est inquiété parce que tout le monde
était piégé par sa belle image elle
était coupée en deux une image
chaleureuse et vivante et derrière elle
était morte
il a pas eu de tuteurs de résilience
parce que vous parlez toujours dans vos
livres du tuteur de résilience alors
c'est terrible à quel point les gens
peuvent être malheureux parce qu il
suffit d fois un jardinier
qui propose un petit enfant de venir
s'occuper des fleurs et ça sert de
twitter de résilience
elle n'a pas eu et pourtant elle a connu
arthur miller qui était un grand
dramaturge elle a connu des hauts et des
madiot que tu as un grand baseballeur et
même si l'une des meilleures relations
avec 10 madiot elle n'a jamais pu
s'accrocher à quelqu'un ou s'appuyer sur
quelqu'un eh bien il aurait fallu
quelqu'un entre dans son monde et à part
le baseballeur ap un joli match aux
personnes a tenté d'entrer dans son
monde parce que ce n'était pas le monde
qui nous faisait plaisir à nous les
norbourg et oui on est en bon avait
préféré se laisser piéger par son image
mais on l'a laissé souffrir et sauf
peut-être le baseballeur qui lui est
elle lui a tendu la main et d'ailleurs
au moment où il était mal elle a
continué à chercher à le voir lui
téléphoner c'était le seul qui la
faisait vivre encore un peu vous auriez
pu l'acquérir vous marine maintenant à
coup sûr
enfin je j'ai réussi à me le faire
croire en toi mais j'aurais mais j'en ai
vu des mallery mode rodez ci com sa
chaleureuse intéressante et qui ont pu
s'en sortir parce qu'elles ont fait une
rencontre ma seule la rencontre
fondatrice celle qui permet de prendre
un virage et elles se sont reconstruites
ensuite vers la rencontre ça peut être
quelqu'un ça fait aussi quelque chose
vous parlez de barbara qui a été
agressée par son père pour chasser par
la gestapo jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans elle
était très mal et elle a découvert la
chanson et la chanson a été pour barbara
une espèce de twitter de résilience
justement oui elle dit elle-même
d'énergie étaient mortes en vain et
l'âge de 25 ans et je m'en suis sorti
parce que je chante mais elle est là
elle était quand même ou blessés
traumatisés un enfant est maltraité un
enfant c'est pas le plus sûr moyen de
rendre heureux
donc elle a quand même été blessée mais
elle a lutté toute sa vie en produisant
des oeuvres d'art de l'affection s'est
engagé sans en parler pour aider les
prisonniers s'est engagé pour aider les
enfants pour aider les anonymes
elle n'a pas dit un mot non et elle
s'engage et elle consacré énormément
d'heures à ça mais elle était blessée
mais elle sa blessure elle a fait
quelque chose elle l'a fait une oeuvre
d'art
nantes dans les traumatismes de
l'enfance vous parlez aussi de niki de
saint phalle or là c'est intéressant
parce qu'on voit comment elle a
transcrit son malheur en oeuvre d'art
avec fameuse nanas de niki de saint
phalle son père l'aimait non pas comme
sa fille mêlée mais comme une femme donc
effectivement et c'est un banquier
pourtant très respectable monsieur de
saint phalle et évidemment il est entré
dans son lit quand elle avait 11 ans et
elle s'en est sortie grâce à son art et
elle l'aimé comme une petite fille aime
soirée hier elle l'aimé d'attachement et
lui il aimait comme une comme on aime
une femme
donc là il ya un contre sens entre les
deux et pour une petite fille c'est
complètement désorganisée qu'est ce que
c'est que ce geste qu'elle se sait que
ce bisou kessous eksmo comprend plus
c'est pas clair les catégories sont pas
claires donc ça c'est très bouleversant
et comme elle pouvait pas agressé son
père otto agressé beaucoup il s'est
coupé la lèvre et s'agresser énormément
jusqu'au moment où elle est devenue
artiste et elle a fait un crypto nîmes
c'est à dire qu'elle donnait à voir et à
entendre ce qu'elle voulait cacher dans
tous les cas vous avez vraiment inventé
un truc qui fait beaucoup de bien c'est
rare les gens qui inventent des choses
qui nous font du bien
tellement de konarka vendre des choses
qui nous font mal c'est vrai
si vous êtes le dire merci merci
beaucoup
à bientôt
le port est sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu